turning overseas to Jerusalem now where
Israeli police overnight stormed a
disputed site that is revered by Muslims
and Jews and fought with Palestinians
that led to other attacks in the region
where all major religions are
celebrating important holidays this week
Charlie dagata has more on the
disturbing scenes of violence
own footage appears to show Israeli riot
police pummeling worshipers with batons
firing stun grenades and rubber bullets
after storming the Al-Aqsa mosque
Israeli police say they launched the
pre-dawn raid after what they called
agitators barricaded themselves inside
releasing this body cam video they say
shows officers coming under attack from
fireworks as they tried to clear the
mosque
they attacked us in their one worshiper
shouts all the young people inside are
suffering and no one is helping them
Israel says more than 350 people were
arrested Palestinians say more than 500
worshipers unlawfully detained the
Al-Aqsa mosque is not only the third
holiest place in Islam it shares a
Hilltop with the Temple mount the most
sacred site in Judaism and the violence
erupted at a sensitive time on the eve
of the Jewish Passover and in the middle
of the Muslim holy month of Ramadan it
triggered a retaliation from Palestinian
Hamas militants in Gaza footage showed a
number of incoming Rockets intercepted
by Israel's Iron Dome defense system the
Israeli Air Force responded with air
strikes on Hamas military sites and even
as they clean up the aftermath of the
Al-Aqsa clashes both sides are bracing
for increased tensions as Passover
begins tonight
for CBS mornings Charlie dagada London